[Música]
aquí
todo flop
muchos de ustedes se preguntarán qué
significa esto
estoy seguro que se van a sentir más
familiar familiarizados con la frase
amor y rigor que es más latina
amor y rigor hace énfasis a la formación
integral de los individuos
con el fin de prepararlos para su óptimo
desarrollo en las vidas
note en esto yo no dije perfecto
desarrollo de sus vidas yo dije óptimo
desarrollo de su vida hago énfasis aquí
porque la vida y el tiempo son variables
el 18 de octubre pasado el presente año
migdonia ayestas directora del
observatorio de la violencia en honduras
expresa que el 55 por ciento de la
muerte en honduras se presenta en una
población menor a los 35 años
es decir que nuestros jóvenes quienes
son el presente y el futuro están siendo
asesinados a causa de drogas robos
violencia y falta de oportunidades
sin embargo sin embargo guadalupe
raudales directora casa alianza en
honduras expresa que aunque se ha
mostrado una disminución en estas cifras
siguen siendo alarmantes son números
según save the children
dice que honduras tiene la tasa de
mortalidad juvenil más alta de toda
latinoamérica
según dicha organización
el 39% perdón según dicha organización
creo que andamos rondando con a nivel
mundial de homicidios juveniles es del 4
por cada 100.000 habitantes
aquí está el dato el promedio mundial es
de 4 por cada 100.000 habitantes en
honduras de un 32.8 por ciento
yo fui parte de varios
de varios programas en donde se ayudaban
a muchachos de escasos recursos
y sin padre
en donde se utilizaba con filosofía de
impacto helios love o solo ama
notamos que la conciencia hacia la
responsabilidad
y la vida
se había dañado al no implementar
conceptos básicos como trabajar por lo
que se quiere o incluso hacerse sentir
merecedores de lo que se está obteniendo
dios los fue un fracaso rotundo pues se
les dio una idea falsa del mundo externo
que los jóvenes necesitan ser
empoderados a muy temprana edad
necesitan ser inducidos a una sociedad
de orden
de respeto y de amor
está claro que es crucial
está claro que es crucial inculcar el
amor
pero también el rigor
porque cambiar una vida de esta
significa cambiar un país significa
cambiar
una generación e incluso el mundo
y crear conciencia de este tipo de
conceptos es importante para el
desarrollo de ellos
cuando hablamos de rigor
hablamos de mostrarle a los jóvenes
límites pero ojo con esto
no limitar su mente ni sus sueños
hablamos de mostrarle a los jóvenes
consecuencias claras
en donde cada acción tiene una reacción
pero tampoco buscamos hacerles sentir
miedo
queremos hacerlo entender el concepto de
este como valor moral
y que lo tome como propio
conciencia de este tipo de cosas son
importantes para el desarrollo de sus
vidas
el 61 por ciento de tráfico de drogas en
honduras se hace por por niños
y hay un 39% hecho por niñas
estas cifras son super alarmantes
tenemos el caso real
de un miembro de soul years
este chico
creció uno de los barrios más peligrosos
de san pedro sula
rodeado
y violencia
crimen sin ningún tipo de guía ni
disciplina
era un ambiente tóxico
no sólo físicamente sino también
emocional
este muchacho para
hacer una idea más clara comenzó a pedir
a temprana edad en los semáforos de la
ciudad
con el tiempo vino el robo
para cuando ya cumplió ocho añitos él ya
estaba haciendo entregas de droga para
pandilleros de la zona
su desesperación no llegó a bloquear
cualquier tipo de conciencia hacia lo
que era lo incorrecto pues era la única
salida que él tenía para poder
alimentarse él
y sus siete hermanitos
creció sin entender el concepto de
lealtad
amor
respeto no había nadie ahí para
mostrarle este tipo de cosas
cuando él pasó a formar parte del
programa souliers nos topamos con el
desafío más grande de nuestras vidas
cómo explicar
y hacer entender que son los valores
humanos pues cómo hacer esto
a alguien que ni siquiera conoce este
tipo de términos
cómo lograr esto cómo lograr hacer
entender esto a alguien
que si para él el robo o la mentira la
manipulación la agresividad eran
naturales para sobrevivir donde él vivía
entonces fue ahí donde empezó el proceso
de impacto
en donde se ataca lo que para soulier
son las los tres pilares fundamentales
en la formación de un muchacho cuáles
son estos tres pilares
pongan mucha atención a esto
mente
cuerpo y alma
vamos a ahondar en cada uno de estos voy
a tratar de definir
los tres pilares vamos a empezar con
mente
cuando hablamos de mente
hablamos de brindar a los jóvenes a
cualquier tipo de oportunidades para su
desarrollo intelectual a qué me refiero
con esto estudios clases técnicas
lenguas
cultura
hablamos de romper paradigmas hablamos
de romper límites les mostramos que hay
un mundo lleno de oportunidades allá
afuera
deseoso de cambio así que ellos pueden
lograrlo y por qué no
los emprendemos queremos que emprendan
queremos que que no le tengan miedo al
fracaso pues están siendo preparados
como guerreros en donde el fracaso
realmente me he visto como tal sino más
bien como
una oportunidad
de aprendizaje para luego volver más
fuertes vamos a definir ahora cuerpo
con este pilar el segundo y no menos
importante buscamos crear conciencia de
que nuestro cuerpo debe ser alimentado
de manera sana
nuestro cuerpo nuestro vehículo de
impacto y de cambio pero usted me
preguntarán cómo haces eso
como logramos influir nosotros en la
cabeza de estos muchachos en este pilar
y ahí es donde entran las artes
marciales
el jiu jitsu el mma son nuestras
herramientas de impacto las artes
marciales nos permiten a nosotros
inculcar honor lealtad nos permite
inculcar respeto
nos permiten presentarles un mundo
diferente y ordenado
con esta con este pilar y me llama mucho
la atención el hecho de que
inmediatamente comenzamos a ver
comportamientos distintos de cuando
ellos entraron
comenzaron a entender
ordene ser árticos
cuando esto pasa se motivaron si vieron
más motivados al cambio
cuando se motivaron al cambio
logramos ver
un aumento en su autoestima
y cuando esto sucede empiezan a
identificar oportunidades
luego vienen los sueños
y cuando esto pasa
nace la esperanza
vamos a definir alma
y esque
todos estos pilares forman una estrecha
relación entre ellos
inquebrantable entonces está claro que
la falta de uno de ellos puede
significar la ruptura del delgado hilo
entre la vida y la muerte en honduras
con este pilar buscamos crear conciencia
buscamos crear líderes
agentes de cambio
buscamos crear con pasión pero también
rigor
en un óptimo balance
soler involucra a los jóvenes en
actividades sociales con el fin de que
se empiecen a familiarizar con este tipo
de cosas
identificamos los lugares de origen
y los empujamos a que retornen allá con
esperanza con luz que se vuelvan agentes
de cambio que se vuelvan héroes
me llama mucho la atención y me gusta
esto porque eso los hace sentir como
de cierta manera presionados de manera
positiva al cambio
al usar al atacar este tipo de áreas
mente cuerpo y alma bajo el concepto de
todo flojo amor y rigor
notamos
que su seguridad
su autocontrol
sus sueños
su vida misma tomo sentido ahora
fue interesante ver casos reales
convertirse en testimonios vivientes
nos
nos reto que preparemos nuestros jóvenes
para el camino y no el camino para ellos
ya que los estamos preparando para
liderar el destino de la humanidad
gracias
[Aplausos]